hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to cannibal cafe now if you
remember the littlest penguin this is a
game made by the same guy and probably
feature something equally is fun or
disturbing because it's called cannibal
cafe and that means you're making sushi
out of body parts for anybody what do
you want oh god why am I playing this
game I don't know I have no idea
well I'm guessing I can assume this oh
jeez oh that's not right how did I make
a turd out of all of that I'm pretty
sure I got that right maybe I need to
look at the recipes Oh
hear me out roll raging heart on roll
the hitch-hiker roll woo these are
horrifying the who knows roll ahh - rice
that's what it [ __ ] not that one
did it no and the eyes gone damn it oh
[ __ ]
I'm not good at this game which I think
it's a good thing considering I don't
want to be good at making cannibal rolls
your eyes to see we'd won row 1 oh go
for it you better get that oh come on it
was right there what a waste
this is [ __ ] okay I'm only gonna do
I can make it illuminati roll ok so yeah
I don't know why I'm excited about this
but BAM you're gonna get what you
deserve and then you want ear me out
rolls don't you I don't remember that
one
I have a bad feeling I'm gonna start
memorizing these things and then trying
to make him on the only maybe hey rice -
seaweed one row one ear BAM oh why is
this normal oh the raging heart on roll
good great oh boy another Illuminati
roll my favorite can't this go any
faster I have no idea I'm not gonna get
yours theyíre me out one I'm not gonna
hear you out oh boy raging hard-on boink
boink boink boink
I need more rice this actually seems
like haven't I played it haven't I
played a game like this before
I'm not unrepresented but I think I have
oh boy that's the complicated one hang
on ok I see you roll
mm okay uh two fingers in one eye okay
race race race row row two fingers one I
will buy a amma and then the nose roll I
don't know if this is gonna get down to
you put back the knife
oh the knife is gonna do am I gonna cut
it up for you can I cut you can I get
some more ingredients why are there so
many cannibals in this town BAM
I need more rice and seaweed thank you
oh boy
one two three one two one two one
BAM Illuminati you're old BAM coming up
I'm I'm surprisingly doing pretty good
at this I'm memorizing the rolls which
is kind of amazing if he asked me okay
that was uh BAM
got it got it got it I'm so rich this is
going so well for me I feel so proud oh
my parents watch this and see what I'm
doing okay you need the raging hard-on
you also need a raging hard-on I got you
covered
if there's one thing the markiplier got
excess of Trajan hard-ons okay I'm not
gonna get to you hold the tongue one
haven't seen that in a while this and
they're all staring at me I just noticed
that the patronage here is a little
little disconcerting whoa is that again
what do they mean
doesn't sound good that's [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] yes you got it all right we're
almost close too late we're closed
hitchhike your way on out of here buddy
unless I got to do it before he goes
away you got my last two stuff oh well
great hmm nice tricks I don't want to do
knife tricks I'll cut off parts of my
own body and then put them in the rolls
I don't think anybody wants that why my
clique is kicking oh boy bring 10,000
total who would play this to get 10,000
yeah tongue roll you got it buddy
I don't know what the knife tricks do
wah wah you all know I don't know I
don't know how to goddamn that was his
tongue roll it's not being a greedy
guess I forgot it already
cuz I'm trying to wipe all this from
mine that's so many people with the
tongue rolls stop it ray
Janardhan got it nail it nail in it nail
it I like I ran away because everyone
kept stealing his rolls yeah I see you
okay
more rice yeah no God so I'm getting
good you know I can't deny Hajis another
I see you roll here we go
nailed it BAM oh boy oh boy just load up
oh man all my money
why doesn't mean to spend all of my
money am I not supposed to fill things
up before they run out ah [ __ ]
it goes all my money god dammit I
thought I was doing good oh geez latona
oh my god dammit I [ __ ] up the tongue
oh that's right who I'm complicated
sorry about the turd on the way down
there hope you all don't mind and I'm
sure you know whoa knife tricks BAM did
it knife tricks night tricks ahoy ah
come on
goddamn it I'm getting off I'm getting
all cocked up what was it oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hear me out hear me out
raging hard-on oh it's too late alright
[ __ ]
god dammit I am not good at this game
I'm not good I don't even know how to do
a knife trick but I made fifty eight
perfect rolls geez
I'm gonna give this one more go and
that's all I'm gonna do because I don't
know how much I can tolerate here
alright this one's gotta be it
okay hear me out I know that one I know
that hitchhiker I know that the dead
thumb and know opposite of that
ya can't forget the money hear me out oh
[ __ ] I just did it man my brain is
working it over to I've got stop staring
at me dude stop it your freaky [ __ ] why
is it over there but I put that over
there
dang it okay the hitchhiker
okay what the [ __ ] was the ear me out
okay Illuminati simple eat eat doll you
lave that's right you better stay right
put give me something hard don't go away
oh you dare no no not that I don't want
to make poop
Tommy making poop out of all this what
am i eating it geez boy I I can't wait
to put these incredible skills on my
resume so that everyone can know the
amazing things I can do with the human
body and not in that way at all not at
that way but the raging hard-on the
raging hard-on give me my money give me
my money give me my money
what god damn and I'm so stupid
you remember anything yes it's the
opposite God why am I so stupid yes I
remembered the ear meow
yeah we're making progress that's good
right I'm happy about that
Illuminati coming up oh boy man oh I
just you know I kind of wonder like you
wonder from a societal standpoint what
the hell happened in this universe that
this is where we are in society like
this is kind of the norm here why are
these people they aren't concerned
they're a little freaky but they don't
seem to be too concerned about anything
and I still don't know how to do a
goddamn knife trick all right I'm gonna
figure that out I'm gonna figure out the
knife trick music oh [ __ ] I don't know
what am i doing stabbing them in the
face oh jeez oh jeez
did it knife trick knifed it up Oh what
what no that's not no no where that when
Oh
bargain [ __ ] but where's my money why
can't I order more I got no money well I
gotta make money to get money this
[ __ ] so we like in the bait in the
beginning of the game I don't even have
the money than a half a four is a bunch
of baloney oh you know I'm gonna you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm
gonna just take a moral stance on this
game I'm gonna take it I'm gonna refuse
service from now on because I suddenly
realize that I was either murdering
people in the back where I was letting
people murder other people just so I
could buy their body parts I don't know
who's on the other side of this phone
here but it can't be good
there's no good to come out of that
phone right there and all of you
[ __ ] can go hungry dang it go eat
some vegetables but I just turn and eat
each other if you're so desperate for
cannibalism they're all just giving me
the oh they're giving me the stink-eye I
think it's like a zombie horde at the
end of this game when you're done and no
one's satisfied and everyone's clawing
at your door you're trying to close it
they're just struggling to get a like
bro stay back stay back we got no more
food we're all out
you want you want [ __ ] rolls I've got
nothing but [ __ ] rolls how about nothing
but eyeball nose wait meh yeah yeah yeah
nitin yeah ha it's kind of a person it's
like a it's like in Full Metal Alchemist
it's all the ingredients you need to
make another human being and so just
turn that into something and I'm sure
everything will go wonderfully you want
it you want it anybody want it I'm
trying to knife trick it kinda
well [ __ ] we're all out of stock oh no
thanks for that there really is
encouraging but you know what I don't
feel too bad so that was cannibal cafe
holy [ __ ]
well now is an interesting experience
but Phillips it's like any other sushi
game that you ever played except with a
horrifying horrible twist and I'd like
to know more about this universe that
we're in where this is the norm but
either way that's the game so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
I'm sure we'll find some way to let you
keep you to see you a mailman is on the
way
Lizzy how do you make a dinosaur get on
the floor open the door get on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur